les travaux des nations unies auquel
participent des diplomates russes sont
depuis plusieurs mois largement affecté
par les multiples refus de visa émanant
des autorités américaines et la
situation ne s'améliore pas bien au
contraire la crise entourant le refus
des visas américains ou représentants
d'états membres s'aggrave les états unis
viole de façon flagrante le droit d'un
certain nombre de pays basé sur la
charte des nations unies de participer
aux travaux des nations-unies les visas
ne sont pas délivrées aux représentants
de la russie qui doivent devenir membre
de la mission ni aux citoyens russes
sélectionnés pour travailler au sein du
secrétariat des nations unies
les visas ne sont pas accordés aux
diplomates russes travaillant au sein de
la mission la semaine dernière par
exemple devait débuter une réunion du
comité des nations unies sur le
désarmement
une rencontre importante alors que doit
être discuté le renouvellement du traité
new start dernier texte sur le contrôle
des armes nucléaires qui lit encore la
russie et les etats-unis mais celle ci a
été reporté de dix jours en raison du
refus américain d'accorder un visa au
chef de la délégation russe
constantine volant sauf qu'ils devaient
participer à la session une situation
délétère dont s'est ému le secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio
gutiérrez dans les choux la question de
la non délivrance des visas des
restrictions de voyage strictes imposées
aux représentants de certains états
membres est une question qui préoccupe
beaucoup le secrétaire général
le secrétaire général et son équipe
juridique continue de faire part de
leurs préoccupations aux hauts
responsables du gouvernement du pays
hôte pour essayer de trouver une
solution à ce problème car la situation
dure déjà depuis plusieurs mois en effet
tout a commencé lors de la soixante
quatorzième session de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies en septembre
dernier à laquelle une partie de la
délégation russe n'avait pu participer
faute de visa malheureusement dix
personnes nombre de la délégation
officielle et accompagnateurs n'ont pas
reçu de visa américain en temps voulu
moi y compris
et c'est ainsi que nous sommes empêchés
de participer aux activités de
l'assemblée générale il s'agit d'un
exemple scandaleux de manque de respect
de la part des états unis d'amérique à
l'égard des membres des nations unies
ainsi que d'un manquement à ses
obligations en tant que pays hôte de
l'organisation mondiale depuis sept au
total une vingtaine de diplomates russes
qui se sont vu refuser un visa américain
alors qu'elle est vouée à être un lieu
d'échangés et de dialogues créée pour
permettre de résoudre les problèmes
le nu est pour ainsi dire prise en otage
par son pays hôte
[Musique]